تهدد بالنووي واشنطن ترد تفضل الدبلوماسيه
ولا نسعى للمواجه
غارات الاسرائيليه على اهداف في قطاع غزه
بعد رشقات صاروخيه من القطاع استهدفت
مستوطنات حدوديه
مجموعه قراصير بوالون لروسيا ترفض هجمات
الكترونيه على مستشفيات في الولايات
المتحده ودول الاوروبيه تدعم اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وفي رده على الالتهابات الكوريه الشماليه
قال البيت الابيض انه يرفض اتهامات بان
التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه مع صول موجهه
ضدها مشيره او مشيرا الى ان الولايات
المتحده ليس لديها اي نوايا عدائيه ضد
كوريا الشماليه وتسعى الى الدبلوماسيه
الجاده كما شدد البيت الابيض على تنفيذ
قرارات مجلس الامن للحد من برنامج الاسلحه
الكوريه الشماليه
ابو رسول العربيه نرشقات من الصواريخ
اطلقت من قطاع غزه باتجاه مستوطنات حدوديه
مع القطاع اعقبها اطلاق صافرات الانذار في
تلك المستوطنات عقب ذلك شن الطائرات
اسرائيليه غارات على اهداف داخل القطاع
يبدو الغارات في مخيم البريجه في مخيم
الان الغارات في مخيم
الان من جديد
في مخيم البناجه على مقربه يعني
الان سنه الدخان
اذا الجيش الاسرائيلي قال في بيان الله ان
الغارات استهدفت موقعه انتاج وتخزين مواد
كيميائيه تستخدمها حركه حماس بالاضافه الى
استهداف موقع اخر تستخدمه حماس لانتاج
وسائل قتاليه وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
الغارات تعد بمثابه ضربه ملموسه لقدرات
حماس في التسلح وبناء القوات العسكريه
وحمل البيان حماس مسؤوليه ما يجري في قطاع
غزه مهددا بدفعها ثمن الخروقات الامنيه
التي تستهدف اسرائيل
على الرغم من حصول المقدسي اكرم عميره على
ترخيص بناء من بلديه القدس التابعه
لاسرائيل الا انه فوجئ باغلاق القوات
الاسرائيليه مدخل بلدته وهدم منشاته دون
سابق انذار انتهاك ياتي بعد اصدار وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
قرارا بهدم اربعه عشر منزلا ومنجره
فلسطينيه في القدس واحنا موجودين في
هالبلد موجودين وعايشين فيها وين اروح وين
نروح
بدهم يطلعون وين بدنا نروح انولدنا هان
وعشنا هان وبنشتغل هان
دوافع انتقاميه وعقاب جماعي لتحقيق مكاسب
سياسيه على حساب الحقوق الاساسيه للمدنيين
هكذا يصف الفلسطينيون اصدار تعليمات لهدم
14 منشاه ومنزلا للفلسطينيين والتي تم
تنفيذ سبع منها في حي الطور وسلوان وجبل
المكبر ومناطق اخرى تعتبر حساسه
واستراتيجيه في القدس معيش قرار ما شكيتش
عليك انا دارك فيها رخصه وبدي اهدها
ظهرني بجاهدها خاوي بجاهدها انا جاي اه
مشكل في حكومه اسرائيل ما في عليك تتحجج
السلطات الاسرائيليه بهدم منشات لانها
بدون ترخيص لكن منشاه المقدسي اكرم عميره
تم هدمها على الرغم من حصوله على رخصه
بناء من بلديه القدس التابعه لا
ودفعه رسوم الرخصه باهظه الثمن الا ان
وزاره الداخليه اصدرت قرارا بهدمها حسب
القانون احنا حملنا حالنا وروحنا حسب
القانون وجبنا اللي هو الرخصه هي
الترخيص حسب القانون
وبرضو مساعده ايش وانا ماشي ولما بنيت حسب
القانون اجوا فحصوني لا يقتصر الهدم على
منزل او منشاه فقط بل على احياء كامله
مهدده بالهدم والاخلاء مثل حي بطن الهوى
في سلوان جنوب المسجد الاقصى في القدس
المهدد بالهدم لاستبداله بحدائق توراتيه
لصالح المستوطنين
هنا في قريه سور باهر في القدس تهدم
القوات الاسرائيليه منشاه لفلسطين قيد
الانشاء بعد اوامر وزير الامن القومي
المتشدد اعتمر بن جبير بهدم اربعه عشر
منزلا للفلسطينيين في القدس على الرغم من
المحاولات العربيه والامريكيه بالتهدئه
لان كلاسي من القدس العربيه
اعلنت السلطات الامنيه الهولنديه قراصنه
الكترونيين موالين لروسيا يقفون على
الارجح خلف هجوم شبراني استهدف مستشفيات
في هولندا ودول اوروبيه اخرى تدعم
اوكرانيا وقالت جهاز مكافحه الجرائم
الالكترونيه الهولندي ان مستشفى يو ام سي
جي في شمال هولندا تعطل موقعه الالكتروني
جرى هجوم سيبراني فيما وضح المركز
الهولندي الوطني للامن السيبراني ان اوامر
الهجمات نفذتها على الارجح مجموعه القرصنه
المواليه لروسيا كلنات ضد بلدات الاوروبيه
تدعم وبلدان اوروبيه تدعم اوكرانيا كما
اعلنت مستشفيات في بريطانيا والمانيا
وفولندا والدول الاسكندنافيه والولايات
المتحده انها تعرضت لهجمات قرصنه
الكترونيه مماثله
ميدانيا سقط ثلاثه قتله في حصيله اوليه
بمدينه كراماتورسكا الاوكرانيه اثر قصف
صاروخي روسي على مبنى سكني في المدينه
وقالت السلطات المحليه ان صاروخ الروسيا
سقط على مبنى سكني في المدينه التي تقع
شرق البلاد وتسبب بسقوط قتلى وجرحى واضرار
كبيره في المبنى ومبان محرطه
اما في مدينه بخموت فقد تمكنت القوات
الروسيه من تطبيق المدينه التي يجري فيها
القتال الان من اجل السيطره عليها من
ثلاثه محاور كما تعمل على طرد القوات
الاوكرانيه من مواقعه وكذا تسلطات المحليه
في جمهوريه لوغانس كالشعبيه ان القوات
الروسيه تحاول الان التقدم الى مدينه
والتي يتم منها قصف سندر وبخموت بشكل مكثف
القوات الروسيه تعمل ايضا بشكل منهجي على
قطع خطوط الامداد والاتصال على القوات
الاوكرانيه في مخموت وحصرها في كماشه في
حين تدور المعارك في ضواحي المدينه
وتحديدا في تلك الاحياء التي سيطرت عليها
الوحدات الاوكرانيه مؤخرا وفق السلطات
المحليه
قال وزير الدفاع
الالمانيوس اثناء زياره سريه
حيث توجد دبابات ليوبار التي تجهز للارسال
لاوكرانيا قال ان علينا طلب انتاج دبابات
لاوبر جديده لتعويض تلك التي سترسلها
المانيا
لكام الحقيقه الحاسمه انه يتعين علينا طلب
دبابات جديده ليس في غضون ام بل باسرع وقت
حتى يمكن بدء الانتاج ويمكننا التخطيط متى
سيكون لدينا عدد دبابات الجديده من اين
ستاتي الاموال دعني اتحدث بصراحه عن هذا
السؤال بصراحه لا اهتم الامر نفسه ينطبق
على امدادات الذخيره اعاده الامداد
المستمر امر مهم وكذلك فيما يتعلق بمساله
مدافع والمركبه المدرعه الاخرى
[موسيقى]
مو سيارتين بدولار واحد فقط عرض امريكي
لاوكرانيا لمساعدتها على الدفاع عن نفسها
في الوقت الذي تستعد فيه لمواجهه هجوم
الروسي جديد قبيل الربيع المقبل
وسيارتان بدولار واحد فقط عرض امريكي
لاوكرانيا لمساعده الاخيره بالدفاع عن
نفسها في الوقت الذي تستعد فيه لهجوم روسي
متوقع قبيل الربيع المقبل فوفقا الامريكيه
شركه جنرال اتوميكس الامريكيه التي تعتبر
من اكبر الشركات للصناعات العسكريه في
العالم عرضت على وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
بيع كل طائرتين من دون طيار من طراز ام
كيوناين ريبرت مقابل دولار واحد الصفقه
ستتطلب منك انفاق حوالي عشره ملايين دولار
لاعاده وشحن الطائرات الى اوكرانيا وحوالي
ثمانيه ملايين دولار الى لكل عام لصيانه
هذه الطائرات من دون طبعا طيار القديمه
والتي لا يتم استخدامها حاليا في اوكرانيا
العرض يشمل ايضا محطه تحكم ارضيه لتشغيل
الطائرات من دون طيار في اي مكان على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وفقا لرساله
قال رئيس تركيا ارسال الدبابات والاسلحه
الغربيه الى اوكرانيا لن يحل الازمه
المندلعه هناك منذ فبراير واضاف اردوغان
ان المحادثات مستمره مع رئيسيين روسي
والاوكراني لتحقيق سلام دائم من خلال
الحوار
وفي اطار الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا نقل
موقع اكسيوس عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين قولهم
ان حكومه نتنياهو تجري مراجعه لسياسه
الاسرائيليه تجاه الحرب في اوكرانيا واضاف
المسؤولون الاسرائيليون ان المراجعه تتضمن
امكانيه امداد كييف بانظمه دفاعيه واوضحوا
ان نتنياهو امر بهذه المراجعه بعد وقت
قصير من عودته للموسم
رد على ذلك حضرت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخرفه اسرائيل من تزويد
اوكرانيا بالسلاح واكدت ان اي اسلحه يتم
تزويد اوكرانيا بها ستكون اهداف المشروعه
للقوات الروسيه
حول بيان الجانب الاسرائيلي بشان تزويد
اوكرانيا بالسلاح نحن لا نقسم الدول وفق
مبدا جغرافي ما نقول ان جميع الدول التي
تزود اوكرانيا بالاسلحه يجب ان تفهم اننا
سنعتبر هذه الاسلحه اهدافا مشروعه للقوات
المسلحه الروسيه
تتابعونا ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد
الفاصل
ليله في حب طلال مداح اكثر من اربعين نجما
عربيا لتكريم مسيره امتدت 50 عاما
اهلا بكم من جديد بحث ولي العهد السعوديه
الامير محمد بن سلمان ووزيره خارجيه فرنسا
كاترين كولونيا التي تزور الرياض اخر
المستجدات الاقليميه والدوليه والجهود
المبذوله تجاهها كما استعرض ولي العهد
السعودي والوزير الفرنسيه العلاقات
الثنائيه بين الرياض وباريس
وسبوله تعزيزها
قالت الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه
التابعه للامم المتحده في تقرير لها ان
ايران ادخلت تعديلات جوهريه على الربط بين
مجموعتين من اجهزه الطرد المركزي لتحصيب
اليورانيوم بنسبه تصل الى 60% في محطه
فوردو دون اعلام الوكاله مشيره الى ان فرق
الوكاله اكتشفت خلال عمليه تفتيش غير
معلنه في المحطه في الحادي والعشرين من
يناير ان سلسلتي طرد مركزي من طراز اي ار
سته
مترابطتان بشكل مختلف تماما عن طريقه
تشغيل التي اعلتها ايران للوكاله من جانب
يعتبر المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
رافاييل جروسي قامت به ايران يتعارضوا
تماما مع التزاماتها الدوليه ويقوض قدره
الوكاله على ضبط الضمانات لمحطه تخصيب
الوقود وتنفيذ اجراءات وقائيه فعاله
هذا اعتبرت الوزيره الفرنسيه لشؤون
الاوروبيه لورانسبون ان نظام الايراني
يغرق في حاله من الانكار ونظريه المؤامره
وقالت الوزيره الفرنسيه ان العقوبات التي
قال النظام الايراني انه فرضها على
الاوروبيين تدل على ان نظامه يعاني من قصر
النظر
اكدت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه اعتراض
شحنه اسلحه ايرانيه كانت متجهه الى اليمن
في الخامس عشر من يناير الماضي وكانت
صحيفه
عن عمليه مشتركه مع البحريه الفرنسيه
لمصادره الاسلحه الايرانيه القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه اشارت الى مصادره
صواريخ موجهه ضد الدبابات كانت ايران
تنقلها للحوث ويبلغ عددها ثلاثه وعشرين
صاروخا كما اكدت القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه مصادره 3000 بندقيه ايرانيه
ونصف مليون طلقه كانت في طريقها للحوصي
وقالت الصحيفه ان العمليه الفرنسيه ضد
الحوثي تاتي ضمن مخطط لاحتوائه انشطه
ايران التخريبيه كما اكدت القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه اعتراض اربع عمليات
تهريب اسلحه ايرانيه خلال شهرين الماضيين
شحنات الاسلحه المهربه تكادلات تتوقف في
اتجاه جماعه الحوث في اليمن مره اخرى في
خليج عمان البحريه الفرنسيه تضبط زورقا
يضم اكثر من ثلاثه الاف بندقيه فضلا عن
نصف مليون رصاصه وعشرين صاروخا مضادا
للدبابات
العمليه جاءت في وقت اصبحت باريس ولندن
تلعبان دورا اكبر في عمليه التصدي لتهريب
الاسلحه في المنطقه بعد ان تصدرت واشنطن
المهمه
المتحدث باسم الاسطول الخامس الامريكي
تموثيوكانز اكد ان الجيش الامريكي ساعد في
مصادره الشحنه
وخلال شهرين تمكنت واشنطن وشركائها من منع
وصول اكثر من خمسه الاف قطعه سلاح ومليون
وستمائه الف طلقه ذخيره الى اليمن البحريه
الامريكيه كانت قد صادرت اكثر من 2000
بندقيه منقارب في خليج عمان كانت متجهه
الى جماعه الحوثي اضافه الى مخدرات تبلغ
قيمتها 33 مليون دولار من سفينه صيد في
المياه الدوليه في خليج عمان الشحنات
المهربه من الاسلحه الى اليمن ليست والده
اليوم في ديسمبر الماضي اعلنت البحريه
الامريكيه مصادره 1400 بندقيه من طراز اي
كي سبعه واربعين من على متن سفينه صيد
شماليه بحر العرب كانت قادمه من ايران كما
صدرت اكثر من مليون ومئه الف طلقه من
سفينه صيد تعمل بين ايران واليمن
فمنذ انقلاب ميليشيات الحوث في اليمن
اواخر عام 2014 كسفت ايران عمليات تهريب
الاسلحه جوا وبرا وبحرا وعبر كل المنافذ
بلال البجدين العربيه
في تظاهرات فنيه سعوديه خليجيه عربيه كبرى
شارك اكثر من اربعين فنانا وفنانا في
تكريم الفنانه سعوديه الراحل طلال مداح
على مسرحي محمد عبده ارينا في الرياض وذلك
ضمن ليله صوت الارض بمبادره من رئيس هيئه
الترفيف السعوديه تركي ال الشيخ
[موسيقى]
اكثر من اربعين فنانا من ثلاثه عشره دوله
عربيه صعدوا على المسرح في ليله واحده
تكريما للفنان السعودي طلال مداح الذي رحل
قبل اكثر من 22 عاما وبعد اكثر من نصف قرن
من عطائه الفني لا يزال راسخا في ذاكره
عشاقه في السعوديه وعموم العالم العربي
كثيره في الفن السعودي
المهمه في الفن السعودي اذا جينا نؤرخ
للفن للغناء بالذات
والغناء جزء مهم من الفن يعني
طلال مداح
ليله تمر
ينط
لق السر فضح ورد
[موسيقى]
ليله صوت الارض الحدث الفني الاضخم عربيا
وعالميا اقيمت في الرياض برعايته الترفيه
السعوديه بحضور الالاف من الجماهير التي
ما زالت تردد اغنيه الراحل حتى يومنا هذا
ومن مختلف الاعمار
سلمت عليه قلت لها ترجم الشيخ فطاربي هو
اتحادي فكان يحسبني ولد عبد المحسن الشيخ
الداعم الاتحاد طلعنا غلبان وقاعد يضحك
وحضني اسمحوا لي اغني اغنيه بالعود بهذا
العود اللي احتفظت ابوه 22 سنه وهو
الاستاذ طلال
[موسيقى]
وقدمت فيك
هذه الليله جاءت بعد مبادره رئيس الهيئه
السعوديه للترفيه تركي ال الشيخ الذي قدم
قبل اسابيع دعوه مفتوحه لكل نجوم السعوديه
والخليج والعالم العربي للمشاركه وهو ما
قبل باستجابه اكبر عدد من الفنانين
والفنانات سعوديا وخليجيا وعربيا انتم
ابناء فنان عظيم من حقكم انكم ترفعون
راسكم في بلدكم اليوم في تكريم ابوكم
يا عمر
شافوني مشغل طلال مداح
فكلن يطلع من عندي ما حد يكلمني
يعني اكون في
صرخه
[موسيقى]
الختام هذا تطير بابرز العرب
نفضل الدبلوماسيه ولا نسعى للمواجه
مباراه اسرائيليه على اهداف في قطاع غزه
بعد رشقات صاروخيه من القطاع استهدفت
مستوطنات حدوديه
مجموعه قراصنه لروسيا ترفض هجمات
الكترونيه على مستشفيات في الولايات
المتحده ودول الاوروبيه تدعم اوكرانيا
نهايه هذه النشره دائما المزيد على
العربيه. شكرا لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]